all right welcome back everyone
um
so in this next session it's going to be
mostly focused more on adaptive
experimental design
but also moving more into hybrid models
where instead of id observations maybe
what observations you have are
reflective of agents different behavior
um
and also if we have uh you know
different an experimental design set up
where you're making treatments and
getting observations but maybe now
there's bleed over between the
treatments and how do you deal with that
and so our first step speaker is kiera
gan
she got a phd in operation research at
cmu
and she's starting as an assistant
professor at orie at
cornell tech
and uh she's an expert in adaptive
criminal design uh causal inferences and
also has a particular focus on medical
applications
um today she's going to talk to us about
her work on adoptive hypothesis testing
thank you so much for the introduction
i just want to mention briefly that i'm
joining cornell attack next fall and i'm
currently doing ph uh postdoc at the
harvard with susan murphy
um so let's get started with this greedy
approximation algorithms for the problem
active sequential hypothesis testing
and let's first start with the fun part
the motivating example so here we are
actually being going to be talking about
cancer research or treating cancer so we
have known for a very long time that the
success of cancer treatment is highly
associated with the stage that cancers
is detected
so nowadays even with very comprehensive
screening policies the percentage of
cancer that's actually being detected in
early stage is quite low so here i'm
taking some statistics from the
canterbury foundation
so ovary cancer is one cancer type that
has established screening policy but
even though only 15 of those cancer
cases are caught in early stages
um and now if you look at the five-year
survival rate for um if you catch this
in early stage versus not uh not early
stage the survival rate drops
significantly
so there has been something
circulating the medical community for a
hope
called liquid biopsy so we all know what
a regular biopsy is right the regular
biopsy simply you have a procedure dig a
tissue out of your body and perform lab
tests to see whether you have um cancer
or not
and what a liquid biopsy is is i want to
kind of still be able to detect cancer
with high accuracy but this procedure
should be minimally invasive and the
idea whole idea is to perform this
procedure using a blood test
so now let me just move on to how this
could actually work in practice right
why we hope that liquid biopsy can blood
tests can be actually used to detect
cancer
so that's actually based on a few facts
the first fact is that cancer is caused
by mutations and our tumor will contain
mutated dna
and the second fact is that when a cell
dies it actually sometimes releases its
dna into the bloodstream so if you have
tumor
then your blood will have tiny traces
amount of mutated dna and that should
serve as a signal for whether you have
cancer or not
right and the um
dna that's circulating in your blood we
just call it the cell free dna
now if we have all the money in the
world this problem is kind of solved
right we can just sequence all your
genetic addresses to see whether it
contains mutated dna then that
i should know whether you have cancer or
not but the challenge here is really the
cost because the human being has three
billion different genetic addresses
right
um
so it just turns out those cell free dna
has very very low concentration of blood
and let me be more precise it's ten to
the minus four
so if you want to avoid a force negative
result you should probably sequence one
particular genetic address for 10 to 4
times
and the cost for that is roughly around
one cent
so now let me just add more constraints
to say that a reasonable commercial test
should cost no more than 100
so this really forces us to pre-select
around 10 to the four number of genetic
addresses in a liquid biopsy panel
right
what we are going to do next is to kind
of reframe this problem in the language
of of active sequential hypothesis
testing and what i'm going to show you
next is just an asht instance and for
now i'm just going to claim that the
problem i just described in words can be
packed into this table with one
additional parameter and let's just work
on the problem set up now
in the problem of active sequential
hypothesis testing we are given a set of
hypothesis right in the cancer example
these are just different types of
cancers that i'm considering that the
patient might have
that corresponds to the rows of this
table
so in this particular example i'm
considering eight different cancer types
so this table contains eight different
rows
so now among one of those hypotheses
is the unknown true hypothesis each star
that i want to identify
all right meaning that one of those
particular roles corresponds to the
cancer that a particular patient
has moreover
we are going to assume that we know the
prior pi
according to which the true hypothesis h
starts drawn
in the cancer example this just
corresponds to that the clinician has a
very good
understanding of the probability
this particular patient to have
different cancer types could be based on
their family history their gender age
and things like that
now in the asht problem we are also
given a set of actions that we could
perform right going back to the genetic
example that just corresponds to
different genetic addresses that i could
potentially sequence and the action in
this table corresponds to a column
right so we have three billion genetic
addresses so we have three billion
columns inside this table
now once i perform an action
i'm going to observe an outcome that's
generated according to the true
hypothesis
and here the outcome is 0 or 1 but it's
not deterministic so i'm with certain
probability i'm going to see a mutation
that's one and with certain probability
i'm going to see no mutation zero
so now what are the entries of this
table right if you think about this
binary outcome distribution it's simply
a bernoulli random variable with a mean
and the mean is specified by the entry
of this table
so under the esht problem in addition to
the setup hypothesis and the set of
actions that we are given
we also know the outcome distributions
for each action and hypothesis pair so
that is given
in the liquid biopsy example this is
short of to say that using past
knowledge past data and domain knowledge
i kind of know for certain group of
groups of patients what's the
probability of observing a mutation
on their certain cancer types
so let me just be more precise with the
binary um bernoulli distribution here
let me just assume that the third row
here is my true hypothesis right the
patient has the this particular type of
cancer
then i perform the action that
corresponds to the first column here
then the outcome that i'm going to
observe
is going to be
1 with probability 0.01
um
now right just to recap the asht
instance you can just think of it as the
prior pi
plus this table that we are seeing here
uh now before i move on i want to
highlight that um the outcome
distribution can actually be more than
bernoulli distribution in our work um it
can also be applied to gaussian
distributions but for the simplicity of
this talk i'm just going to be focusing
on this this bernoulli case throughout
so now have having stated the input to
the asht problem right what is the
objective
i know the set of hypothesis i'm given
the set of actions right i also know the
outcome distributions that i will
observe once you perform an action
the goal is to kind of again identify
the unknown true hypothesis h star
with high probability
at minimum expected cost
right again without the cost constraint
this problem is trivial
so to denote and just to formally denote
this probability of identifying the true
hypothesis i need one more parameter
delta
to denote again the probability of
identifying the wrong hypothesis
and formally stated right the goal of an
asht problem is to identify the unknown
true hypothesis h star with high
probability
at minimum expected cost
now if you abstract the way and think
about in terms of the lipibs example
this is to say that we want to identify
it doesn't matter what cancer type that
this patient has when my algorithm
terminates i kind of want to identify
this correct cancer type with high
probability
right so there's kind of some fairness
inside this objective
you want to be fair to on unknown
hypothesis h star
so it turns out that this problem isn't
hard and we don't have an exact solution
for this so we will be focusing on um
discussing two approximation algorithms
in this talk
um and we will consider two types of
adaptive algorithms
all right so the first type of adaptive
algorithm is partially adaptive
meaning that i'm going to first
fix my action sequence according to some
objective greedy objective
then i'm going to play the actions in my
action sequence one by one
and once the algorithms accelerating
criterion has
met then i'm going to terminate
so really the key part is how do you
construct this action sequence
beforehand without knowing which one is
the true hypothesis
and to provide theoretical guarantees
under um this partially adaptive
algorithm we're going to be using a tool
called submodular function ranking from
kind of discrete optimization world
and one of the objectives of this talk
is to simply introduce you what this
tool is
and the second type of adaptive
algorithm that we consider is the fully
adapted algorithm so at this time you
can perform actions one by one
you are going to see the outcome
from your previously performed actions
then based on that information you are
going to select the action to perform in
the next step
and also you're going to adaptively
terminate the algorithm
and to provide stereotype theoretical
guarantees we will be using tools from
optimal decision trees
now before i move on to introduce you
the two algorithms
in our work first i want to show you a
summary of the results
so we will first look at our partially
adaptive algorithm and compare against
two benchmarks one is just brute force
right i can just um
search through all the action sequence
and find the best permutation in a
partially adaptive case and then we will
compare it also against to uh lp
heuristic that's from past literature
so this is kind of an algorithm that you
are constructing one randomized policy
to play according to
at each iteration
and then we will
look at two performance metrics one is
runtime the other one is approximation
ratio
and just for reminder approximation
ratio is the ratio between the objective
of an algorithm to that of the optimal
algorithm so here i will not define what
an optimal algorithm is but i will
formally state it later on so here just
to give you a sense of how those three
algorithms compare
so for brute force you do because you're
searching through all the action
sequence you get this a factorial
runtime
for the lp heuristic
again we're just coming up with one
randomized policy to perform according
to at each time step
this really corresponds to solving one
linear program
with size
a times h squared
and to the best of our knowledge this lp
heuristic algorithm doesn't have any
approximation guarantees
and now for our algorithm
the wrong time right to construct this
action sequence it is linear in the
number of action and number of
hypothesis per iteration but our
algorithm also admits approximation
guarantee of log h
now to see the fully adaptive case again
we are going to
compare our fully adaptive algorithm
with brute force and this algorithm
proposed by nashville and javidi in 2013
this is a two-stage algorithm that used
the first
lp heuristic as a stage one policy
and then once the posterior probability
of a hypothesis exceeds certain
threshold i'm going to move into stage
two
so for stage two i'm going to solve a
different linear program each iteration
right to coming up with a randomized
policy that favors that particular
hypothesis exceeds
exceeding my threshold so that's um
the runtime is
solving lp per iteration with size
linear in the number of action times
number of hypotheses
now our algorithm has a similar
runtime per iteration but we have
approximation guarantee of log square h
so this is just a summary of our results
any questions so far
elaborate on the cost here so the cost
is the number of addresses that you
check yes
samples here we're just
considering uniform costs so each
sequencing each genetic address will be
cost the same
so the cost is just the number of
addresses that you perform and it's a
probabilistic guarantee is a constraint
i need to reach this one minus
yes
yes exactly yes
regarding the iteration cost how many
iterations
so
so for this
you can kind of thinking i'm going to
construct an action sequence right
but i don't need 3 billion i don't need
the full permutation of the entire
action sequence i can truncate maybe at
300 500 things like that
and we're looking at the order like
around hundreds and thousands uh for
iterations so like usually in our
experiments with the cancer example our
algorithm usually terminates before
performing like 800 actions
well yeah that corresponds to example
complexity that you will need
two tournaments
uh
you know that we you will be put reading
that
in the paper i think
this paper they had something that's
similar to
um
the sample the samples that you need to
terminate
but this is
but it will depend on the gap right so
the two hypotheses which are very close
it can take forever
yeah it depends on like the stopping
point for the malaria
but in terms of that like it's an extra
gauge
so compared to like typical banded stuff
you require that the algorithm is able
to verify that it has found the correct
hypothesis right this is harder because
you ask the audience to also tell you
that i'm sure
you need to be able to
it's identification
the main difference is that
if you sense the same address twice you
get the same outcome here
is you will get different outcomes
normally
right yeah security actually don't so
when you perform an action you actually
see binary outcomes with certain
probabilities yes and so if i perform
the same action
now i get two different outcomes for the
same one
here is one
here because i said it like in biology
it would be worse okay i see that it's a
new measurement new noise somehow
okay so the idea behind the biology is
that even you sequence the same genetic
address twice
it's not guaranteed that you're going to
see a mutation because some
sequence continues
to think about the noise
the same table entry twice
so the answer will not change because
that's the name of the
i
but now i'm confused now so if you can
probe the same column more than once why
is the optimal solution occurring
like issues like the optimal
solution might involve probably the same
um so you don't know which cancer type
if you go to the results table
um
i thought the runtime of the brute force
is like
oh yeah
okay so i think to
yeah i think maybe already practice
group was probably terminates earlier
eight factorial
number of actions right
do you need to assume anything about the
gap
okay that's something i'm hiding um so
we do have would you require a parameter
on the minimum separability of the
entries in the table
so
so right
um we require like the cal divergence
between those two distributions is
separated by a center called s
and that's uh that's a parameter
language on which like our theoretical
guarantee will depend on
right usually expect the smaller the gap
is the worse
the approximation guarantee is right
but for some psp i'm just hiding back
under here the dependence is uh
um
proportional to one over us
um so
what i'm going to do next is really to
show you how the partially adaptive
algorithm will work and the way that i
will do that is first to give you some
intuition of how we would proceed even
to think about this problem in partially
adaptive case
and the way that we're going to do that
is by reducing this um stochastic
outcome to deterministic outcome let's
first to say that
if i perform the action and it gives me
binary outcomes then how when when an
algorithm will say that i have
identified the correct hypothesis
so here we have the table like we had
before right each each row corresponds
to a hypothesis and each column
corresponds to an action
however now if i perform an action
right under any hypothesis i'm going to
deterministically see either zeros or
ones
right and let me simplify this problem
further for you to say that i know that
row one is my true hypothesis right my
goal is to identify this hypothesis by
performing
actions let's just walk through one of
such exercise right let me um just going
to pick
this arm one that corresponds to
the first column
when i perform this action a1 because i
know that my true hypothesis is h1 so
the outcome that i will observe will
correspond to the entry zero here
now if i look at the entries of the res
tables that corresponds to a1
the only inconsistency that i will see
in the potential outcome will be the one
that corresponds to my hypothesis 6.
so by performing this action a1 now i
can say that i have ruled out
hypothesis 6 to be my true hypothesis
so i'm going to keep performing more and
more actions until there's only one left
and then at that time i'm going to say
that i have identified the correct
hypothesis
all right so this is not to say that i'm
showing you an optimal action sequence
in any sense but to see how ruling out a
hypothesis would work in a deterministic
case
now going back to our stochastic
instance
let's just think how we would approach
this right how would we rule out one
hypothesis
so let's just go over the same exercise
let's say suppose row one is my true
hypothesis
one very natural idea is to say i'm
going to rule out another hypothesis
if the log likely reach log likelihood
ratio between those two hypotheses
exceeds certain thresholds right so what
is the log likelihood ratio
i just need one more parameter to denote
the outcome that observe at time i
when action ai is performed
then the log like a hud ratio between h1
h2 will simply looks like like the
following right in the numerator here we
have the probability of observing o i
under
uh my hypothesis 1 and 8 1 as my kind of
data generating process and in the
denominator we're simply replacing h1
with h2
and we're summing over all the actions
that we have performed so far here
so now this expression actually has a
problem
what is that
right um so
the problem is actually this oi that i
observe at each time i is random right
so this quantity
depending on the path would actually be
different
for different realization
so
this causes a problem because we're
saying we're ruling out a hypothesis
according to some random quantity and we
do not want that
so the solution that we come up with is
simply to take the expectation of this
of this quantity when we are performing
the ruling out step
so it turns out that the expected log
likelihood ratio is a very nice looking
form right it simply is the sum of the
kale divergences specified by my um
the bernoulli distribution uh
specified by h1 and ai
and the bernoulli distribution is
specified by h2 and ai
so kind of the idea here is really you
are collecting more and more cal
divergences by performing more actions
right to kind of uh give you the
confidence of how those two hypotheses
how well
how to rule out one hypothesis
so let me just make this more this idea
more concrete uh when i move into the
partially adaptive algorithm
you will see we will use that um idea
that we just talked about as a
subroutine
so for our partially adaptive algorithm
let me just give you the outline of the
algorithm again so the input is going to
be an esht instance
again it's the prior pi and the table
that we've seen in the previous slides
and we also are given the error
tolerance delta
all right so what i want is when an
algorithm terminates i want
my algorithm to be able to identify the
correct hypothesis with probability one
minutes delta
i will construct the action sequence
according to the greedy objective that i
will describe later
now here we are going to boost
each action in my sets for sufficient
many times to obtain sigma tilde this is
because um
this is because we want to kind of
because of stochastic nature of our
instance we want to perform an action
sufficiently many times to be able to
see
say the difference between two
hypotheses
and now what we are going to do next is
by performing the action in the superset
one by one and terminate only there's
only one hypothesis left
so to create the greedy objective um for
constructing the action sequence we will
be using this tool called submodulator
function ranking again this will use the
intuition that i talked about as a
subroutine
so here we will ident so the goal for
some modular function ranking is to
identify
or cover a hypothesis
so at each time step
right we will consider a true hypothesis
h
and then i'm just going to use this
capital letter s to denote the set of
actions that we have performed so far
and i have a threshold
for
when to say that i've collected enough
cal divergence to rule out a hypothesis
so
so the first thing that we need to keep
track of is the progress that we have
made so far towards ruling out a
particular hypothesis gene under h
all right the way that we are going to
do that is by using the following
function capital k
subscript by h and g
inside the minimization term we have our
threshold b and in the summation here
we're simply calculating the cal
divergence that we have collected so far
in my action set us
right so if i've performed enough action
i'm going to hit my threshold b and this
function will take the value one
so a sanity check right
this function takes the value of 1 if i
only if i have ruled out hypothesis g
under h
and the minimum value for this function
0.
now the second thing that we need to
keep track of right to identify h i need
to rule out all the other hypotheses in
my sets
i kind of also need to keep track of the
progress that i've made towards
identifying h
so the way that we will do that is by
using this function f subscript by h
all right in the summation here
we're simply summing over
the progress that we are making towards
ruling out each individual hypothesis in
my set that's not h
right
so this function will take the value 1
if and only if i have ruled out all the
other hypothesis in my set and this is
to say that h is identified
so for those of you who cares um this
function is actually submodular
and now we can talk about
the greedy algorithm that we used to
construct the action sequence
so
so far for some modular function ranking
we have a function that
keep track towards of ruling out all the
other hypotheses
in my sets so here overall how we're
going to construct the sequence if i do
not know the underlying true hypothesis
h
right
so at each step we keep track of this
set of actions that we have performed so
far using this capital letter s
and then at each step i'm going to
choose the action has the following
highest score
now in the numerator here this is simply
the incremental coverage
with one additional action
and in the denominator here we are just
favoring the hypothesis that is about to
be covered
we are wait we are waiting this
fraction using the prior for each
hypothesis and here we are summing over
our uncovered hypothesis
so that's our greedy objective
so using this 3d objective we will be
able to calculate the action sequence
and do what we
just said before in the algorithm
outline and here i want to just say that
so when do we determine that my
algorithm will stop right i have my
action sequence i perform the actions
one by one
then my algorithm will terminate when
the log likelihood ratio
between one hypothesis and the remaining
hypothesis is above a certain threshold
so this actually depends on the
realization
of the
of the instance
so now just to state the
theoretical theoretical guarantee for
the partially adaptive algorithm
formally
i'm going to introduce a notion of delta
error algorithm
so
so i'm going to be called an algorithm
that satisfies this delta error
property if it identifies any true
hypothesis with probability one minus
delta
now for our partially adaptive algorithm
we can show that our proposed partially
adaptive algorithm achieves this delta
error with expected cost almost the
following amount times the optimum so
what's the optimum the optimize the
minimum cost algorithm among all
partially adaptive algorithms that
achieves delta error
now to parse this
um
to parse this term here i'm going to be
looking at the special case where delta
equals to
h to the minus c if you're plugging this
value to your expression you actually
get the following approximation ratio
and i want to highlight that the first
term is the approximation
ratio lower bound for the esht problem
so this is really to show that
our approximation guarantees tight with
respect to this parameter h
so now i'm going to quickly run through
the fully adapted algorithm
so now the challenge is to
kind of incorporate
the observations that you have made so
far towards selecting the next action
and the way that we will incorporate
that part of the information is by
creating this idea of a live set
so the set of a life hypothesis are the
ones that are consistent with my
previously observed outcomes
so to remove the noise right from the
problem instance we're going to repeat
each action sufficiently many of times
right that's how we reduce to the
optimal decision tree problem
and then we're going to really choose
the meta action that rules out the most
alive hypothesis in the worst case
so once we perform the action
we're going to see outcomes and we're
going to take the empirical mean of the
outcome
right at this time step i'm going to say
i will rule out those hypothesis that's
inconsistent with the empirical outcome
that observed
all right um so again um we will
terminate this algorithm when there's
only one hypothesis that's left in my um
set
so quickly running through the
theoretical guarantees um we have just
the same setup as we had in the
partially adaptive case
just the
approximation ratio is slightly
different
we will do the same exercise by
substituting delta equals to h to the
minus c
and that's how you get the log square
each term here in approximation factor
moving on to experiments um
you guys have
seven minutes
okay
so let's skip the synthetic synthetic
parts
um so cosmic is the
public data set for genetic mutations so
you will in this data set you will
observe the genetic mutation for each
cancer patients
um
curated over the past history
now what we are doing in this table here
is we are looking at eight different
cancer types so that's a different
hypothesis
and we're looking at genetic
genetic
address intervals as our action space
so the x-axis here are
the accuracy of the algorithms so we're
looking at four different algorithms in
this figure
and the y-axis is the average number of
samples that are used
um
when the algorithm terminates
so we're comparing the lp heuristic
that's the benchmark for the partially
adaptive algorithm against our adapt our
partially adaptive algorithm that's nj
adaptive so that's the first solid line
there
and we are
comparing um
[Music]
actually adaptive algorithm
what
sorry
so we are comparing the performance
sorry i got that wrong so we are
comparing the performance of the lp
heuristic with our partially adaptive
algorithm that's the second dash line
there and then we are comparing the
algorithm proposed by nashville and
javidi for their two-stage um two-stage
algorithm here that corresponds to the
first solid line and the performance of
our our algorithm that's the bottom
solid line here
um
kind of the overall message here is our
proposed algorithm does outperform the
existing benchmarks um
i guess
the key key question that you're asked
is probably what's the sensitivity and
specificity and those are kind of
important uh in the medical test and
here are the results um if you
think about the objective of
asht problem
it is kind of saying that condition on
that this patient has a particular
cancer right when my algorithm
terminates
i want to have delta probability of
identifying the wrong hypothesis it's
kind of the sensitivity of a cancer
test so here we do see that um our
algorithm achieves quite high
sensitivity and specificity in general
um
compared to the existing liquid biopsy
tests which i'm not showing here
but that concludes the entire talk thank
you so much for your attention
give time for a few questions
um so can i treat the theorems
as bounds on stopping time
like the first is it the number of
it's not the cause so we're comparing
the performance of our algorithm to that
of an odds
so we're not really characterizing the
optimum policy we're not saying when the
optimal policy determines how many
samples are given
but to compare the performance of our
proposed policy with that of the optimum
policy
so this is why
yeah so no so the approximation
guarantee is independent of the actions
so that's the key part right when the
action space is very large this results
kind of nice because your approximation
guarantees independent of the number of
actions
um so i like this uh seeing that
function in some of the chaos as a
submodular function
could you just solve for like could you
have made it a continuous problem
then so it's like you're trying to solve
for a probability distribution over the
actions
and then use some rounding technique
um to do it
did you guys think of that as just like
i'm just curious
um
so have you done any cost of adaptivity
in our sense like for example how does
the
like
partially adaptive solution compared to
the pulley
um
so we do have the performance here
um
comparing the partially adaptive
solution to a partially adaptive path
um
can you compare the partially adaptive
solution to a fully adapted position
in terms of number of samples yeah so
yeah so here's experience like we don't
have very full results for that because
we are not considering simple complexity
as a metric right we are comparing just
two outs of
the performance of ours our weather
against ops um but like
for the numerical experiments right
those are at the same accuracy right if
you reach the same accuracy you will see
that pulling partially downtime
algorithm requires a lot less samples
than the partially gapped algorithm and
that's minus our intuition right that
should be the case in practice
so yeah
i hope that answers that question
right so for partially adaptive
algorithm you will construct the action
sequence
inquiry so once you run the reading
algorithm to construct your action
sequence that action sequence six
now you perform the actions one by one
and then your adapter may choose one to
stop
you don't have to run through all the
actions
okay so it's it's basically
sequence
and then as you go stop early if you
want
that's right
okay
you